vous ne connaissez certainement pas leur
visage
mais vous avez à coup sûr déjà croisé
l'une de leurs oeuvres
tous trois sont autodidactes ils ont
tapé en graff est dans la rue en mode
vandales sur le bordel y aurait passé
son tout ce qu'on fait du vandale et
qu'on fait c'est légalement on serait un
monstre est peut-être pas là aujourd'hui
maintenant à faire ça comme ça comme la
plupart j'avoue j'en ai fait j'en ai
fait un petit peu il ya huit ans et tant
que ça donc voilà bombe a très vite
monsieur arrêtez maintenant je fais
beaucoup plus de terrains parce que le
vandale
c'est beaucoup de risques pour pas grand
chose en fait aujourd'hui ils gravent
dans des espaces désaffectés ou sur des
surfaces dédiées comme pour cette toute
première battle trois styles trois
artistes fiers de présenter leur art au
grand public
je fais un crayonné après je jamais
tenues couleur principale et au fur à
mesure je vais remettre mes petites
strates c'est à dire mais très noir ou
de couleurs ses dépens le travail
montrer ce qu'on sait faire et à
valoriser dans leur garde mais tout le
monde ne le vois pas quoi même public
qui voit ce qu'on fait une initiative
organisée dans le cadre de jaune 61
un festival dédié aux cultures urbaines
à alençon
les graffeurs là c'était une première
d'organiser un battle de graff et c'est
vrai que c'est le côté on va dire le
plus obscur de
du monde un peu du hip hop ces personnes
qu'on voit moins on leur tire à coups de
boulets rouges quand ils font des
bêtises mais ils font pas que des
bêtises ils font des choses bien et puis
on est là pour les mettre en avant pour
pour faire voir l'émergence des cultures
urbaines
au final c'est jonathan alias dione 99
qui remporte le concours
son oeuvre sera exposé lors de la battle
hip hop international organisé samedi
prochain à lens